should you buy a Windows laptop or a
Macbook well the choice could be very
tough and both systems have their
positives and negatives so I'm going to
go over everything and make it very easy
now a few years ago I would absolutely
say MacBook but ever since Apple started
making their own chips it forced Windows
laptops to really step it up and now
these machines are actually way more
compelling now of course if your budget
is 300 bucks Apple doesn't have anything
that will compete with that so I'm going
to be focusing on a little bit more
powerful computers I have this Lenovo
here which is an amazing bank for the
buck with a powerful I9 processor and
RTX 4070 graphics and I'm going to be
talking about a few different Mac PCS as
well starting off with design Windows
laptops has gotten a lot better this
Lenovo is super sturdy it looks nice
slightly gamish but it feels way better
than what we had in the past and of
course with the max we have a very
similar aluminum clean design and one
area where PC laptops usually win are
the ports Apple limits you they want you
to pay more whereas most Windows laptops
have usba a ports still and this one has
a bunch it even has them in the back so
you can get them out of the way so
connectivity is better now with that
Windows laptops sometimes have smaller
batteries but they are getting better
and this lovo has a 99.9 W battery which
is the maximum you could put on an
airplane and because of that the battery
life can be better but with that as well
we have this massive power brick
compared to the small ones on an Apple
MacBook now that is because more
powerful Windows laptops use a lot more
wattage and they need that power and
we'll talk about performance on battery
in just a bit you also typically get
better bang for the buck because this
thing comes with a terabyte of SSD 16
gigs of RAM compared to MacBooks where
you have to pay extra and Apple rips you
off like crazy and what I love even more
about Windows laptops are that many of
them will let you upgrade them and some
just have extra slots so for example
here for about 50 bucks I can add 16
more gigs of RAM and pop it in leaving
the original one there and same thing
with the SSD there's an extra slot so I
can pop it in myself and for about 50
bucks make it a two terab whereas Apple
will charge you an arm and a leg for
their upgrades and then it's all oted in
so you can never change it later you
might just have to sell your machine to
get one that has more performance now
the ssds are also very fast on the new
Windows laptops whereas in the past
MacBooks used to be much faster but one
area where I've noticed a big difference
is in real world transfer speeds where
the whole system really slows down
compared to using the same drive on a
Mac with that another cool thing Windows
laptops allow you to do is to use egpus
like this one from our partner sgw Zone
this egpu is is very unique because of
how tiny it is compared to the huge
egpus most people are used to that have
to stay at your desk we have the 3D
printed prototype whereas the final will
be aluminum and they will also provide
an oculink module the reason it's so
small is because it uses a gan power
supply with 240 WS of power meaning you
could take it with you anywhere to
upgrade your thin laptop for better
gaming rendering and AI Computing inside
we have an AMD RX 6600m which beats out
the M3 and can improve your thin
laptop's performance and and an Nvidia
RTX 460 and 3070 will be available all
you do is plug in with Thunderbolt and
you get a thunderbolt USBS and display
outputs with ak60 and 4K 120 support
plus this customizable LCD screen which
is a first for an egpu it is universal
and also less expensive than other egpus
so check out this thin gaming and AI Box
by using the link down in the video
description as for displays MacBooks are
better most of the time especially the
higher-end ones that that have mini LED
screens now you can get oleds on Windows
laptops and those are nice but they're
still very reflective so in the daytime
the blacks can actually look more gray
than the MacBook and this Lenovo has an
LCD display they've gotten more accurate
over time but it is a matte display and
it makes it look less sharp even though
it has good resolution now the
higher-end MacBooks also have promotion
so it's very smooth but with that it can
actually lower down the refresh rate to
save battery life whereas this is 240 HZ
but you can only drop it to 120 or 60 so
you can never get a variable you have to
just choose do you want worse battery
life or do you want smoother display and
I'll talk about battery life in just a
sec the webcams on MacBooks are
typically better as well especially now
that they're mostly 1080p with that the
speakers are also better as well even a
thin Macbook will be louder and sound
better than thick Windows laptops
because Apple puts a big Focus on it go
ahead and listen to this
[Music]
comparison now one area where Windows
laptops succeed are the programs that
are compatible Mac supports less and
there are some exclusives like logic and
Final Cut but on the window side Da
Vinci resolve is so good now it's
actually better and there are certain
programs that just don't run on a Mac
same thing with with games if you want a
game the Windows PC is definitely the
better way to go getting into downsides
we have to talk about fan noise and
temperatures Macs like to run hot
because Apple wants them to be quiet
whereas Windows laptops the fans could
be running just by turning on a program
or opening the laptop and for higher
performance ones like this Lenovo they
have great cooling systems and to get
the most performance you have to be in
performance mode and then they sound
like a jet taking off because they can
use up to 880 wat WTS of power on the
system compared to 22 Watts on an
equivalent Mac now as far as performance
they are actually not too far off when
you're comparing to similar price points
Intel has made processors that are way
more performant now even though they
take a lot of power and the graphics
with Nvidia are extremely fast in our 4K
gaming test we got 142 FPS compared to
79 and even exporting video took a
minute and 5 Seconds compared to a
minute and 21 and then in RAW graphics
performance it gets 16 FPS for D noising
compared to 9 that is almost double the
performance and the Nvidia cards are
just incredible now so if you want to
get bang for the buck in terms of raw
power well they are very good now Mac
are optimized for certain things and of
course if you spend a lot more money
they will beat out the Windows laptop
but if you're looking at similar price
points well the windows will get you a
better price as long as you are plugged
in and this is where I get to probably
the biggest downside for me personally
with Windows laptops that are on the
more powerful end you get great
performance where you're plugged in but
if you unplug it it can go south fast in
geekbench we got
10,711 compared to
12,100 and that is in the most powerful
performance mode on this laptop which
this laptop actually holds up way better
than a lot of other laptops I've tested
and in terms of graphics performance we
went from
11,800 to
8,100 so that's a big dip in terms of
rendering and then for gaming
performance or for other Graphics tasks
we went from 142 FPS down to
75 which is worse than a bin slower 14in
M2 Pro and in photo editing instead of
taking a minute and 19 seconds took a
minute and 46 compared to a MacBook
which cost the same that takes 45
seconds regardless if it's plugged in or
on battery so even with the most
expensive MacBooks if you're unplugged
you're still going to get the same
performance and with Windows laptops
even in a medium range they slow down
but if you looked at a $4,000 Windows
laptop for example a razor blade with
the OLED screen that thing dumps
performance even more than this one so
if you like to use your laptop unplugged
on the go on an airplane well the Mac is
way better and this is where we have to
get into battery life the M3 Max 16in
got over 17 hours compared to 9 hours
with an equivalent Dell XPS even with a
large battery that just shows you guys
the difference and that is in Balance
mode where it will try to save power
whereas on the Mac you just leave it in
Auto if you need the performance it'll
give it to you or it could save battery
now it gets way worse if you really
start pushing the system that XPS will
last two 2 hours compared to 6 on the
MacBook and because it's unplugged it
will be a lot slower as well with this
Lenovo I was at about 50% battery and
just having the system on gave me a
little more than an hour and then when I
started doing some photo editing it
showed me 35 minutes when I'm in the
performance mode and like I showed you
in that mode it is still way slower than
a Mac and with that we should talk about
resale value because a Mac can be
similarly priced depending what you're
buying or more expensive especially if
you start doing Apple's ridiculous
upgrades but in the long term people are
still selling 10-year-old MacBooks
5-year-old MacBooks and getting a good
amount of money for him where it is so
hard to sell a Windows laptop after the
first couple of years trust me I sell
these machines after I test them and use
them and it is so hard to sell and you
get barely anything so in the long run a
Mac can actually be cheaper but if you
know exactly what you need if you care
about performance you might not care as
much about the speakers and the display
you're going to keep it plugged in
you're going to get a lot more value
from the Windows laptop especially if
you have certain programs or games that
you want to use which you might not be
able to on a Mac so there you guys go
let me know your thoughts and questions
down in the comments section below click
that Circle to subscribe and check out
one of those great videos right over
there this has been Max and I'll see you
in the next one